welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of Scream
the 1996 slasher classic that reinvented
everything we know about modern pop
horror with dozens of Winks by director
Wes Craven and impressive attention to
detail that often goes overlooked and
this video is sponsored by Squarespace
the all-in-one platform that makes
launching your website of Breeze this is
a movie I rewatch every October and it's
the first horror film my parents let me
watch as a kid or at least the first one
I got away with watching when my older
sister rented it from Blockbuster
remember Blockbuster that was also a
thing from the '90s but this movie
totally holds up as an impressive who D
it with a ton of interesting Clues to
dissect all of them pointing to how
exactly the two killers work together
and since I really have screamed to
thank for becoming YouTube's Randy Meeks
I'm going to break down every clue and
reference and detail that you might have
missed okay the film opens on a ringing
landline which yes totally dates the
film but this specific generation of
phone is crucial to the scene and to
screams function as a '90s film
influenced by a generation of 80s
slasher movie pop culture cordless
landline phones were only started to
become a household Staple in the '90s
and cellular phones were a tech Marvel
used only by serial killers apparently
this opening scene wouldn't work quite
the same with a cell phone or a
smartphone a challenge scream sequels
have really had to contend with we meet
Casey played by Drew Barry Moore
Barrymore was the biggest name in the
cast in 1996 but this was all by Design
they wanted us to go into this movie
thinking we'd be following her we see
Casey popping popcorn the first of many
references to the John Carpenter classic
Halloween popcorn is the same snack
Annie makes and it gives this opening
sequence a natural tension because that
foil just gets bigger and bigger and
bigger really anytime you watch scream
at an outdoor movie screening some
douche is inevitably going to yell but
what about the popcorn we see Casey has
rented two VHS tapes Halloween and
Children of the Corn too so like jam Lee
Curtis the star of Halloween Drew
Barrymore was born of Hollywood royalty
too Drew Barrymore was the daughter of
several generations of actors including
Lionel Barrymore the villain from its
Wonderful Life and jam Curtis was the
daughter of Tony Curtis and Janet Lee
who played a similar role in Alfred
Hitchcock Psycho that Drew Barrymore
does here Drew Barrymore wears a
platinum blonde wig as an homage to
Hitchcock as Hitchcock had a penion for
casting blondes as his murder victims
Hitchcock was actually quoted as saying
just think of the shock value killing
off your Leading Lady halfway through I
mean you are intrigued are you not I
don't have a great Hitchcock sorry about
that like Janet Lee Drew Barrymore was
featured prominently in the marketing
and shocked audiences with an earlier
than expected death that made us think
anyone in this movie could die the
scream series would go on to kill a
variety of other big stars in the early
minutes of the films Drew Barrymore
accidentally called 911 for real while
filming the scene because the prop
Master forgot to unplug the phone the
voice on the other end is actually actor
Roger Jackson whose other most famous
villain role is as Mojo Jojo and the
Powerpuff Girls I would pay all the
money in the world for a re-edit of this
movie where it's Mojo's voice ta to the
main characters of the phone you hang up
on me again I'll got you like a fish
hold on there's someone on the other
line is this some kind of joke but the
Ghost Face Killer we later learn is
actually Billy and Stu working together
two people so it really reframes what's
actually happening in in this opening
sequence Stu is the more Savage of the
two killers and slashes more recklessly
he's actually the one who kills Steve
the guy in the Letterman jacket whereas
Billy likes to play games and it's more
likely him speaking over the phone he
tends to strangle and weaken his victims
before stabbing them more ceremonially
so it's him over Casey later but it's
probably Stu who strung up Casey over
the tree for reasons we'll get to later
actually this whole cold open is
inspired by two early slasher films When
a Stranger Calls and black Christmas
both of these include scenes where the
killer taunts their victims over the
phone black Christmas Even has villain
in it named Billy all of these movies
though are ripping on the urban legend
the babysitter in the man upstairs which
usually ends with the famous Stinger the
call is coming from inside the house now
the call isn't coming from inside the
house here technically but you know very
near it Casey and the killer move on to
talking about a Nightmare on Elm Street
and Casey says the first one was with
the rest sucks ah yes Wes Craven the
director of this movie directed the
first Freddy movie but none of the
sequels except Wes Craven's New
Nightmare in 1994 the other movie he was
directly involved with was Nightmare on
El Street part 3 which he co-wrote and
it's worth mentioning that part three
totally kicks ass West Craven went on to
direct screams 2 3 and four apparently
he learned the lesson about turning your
franchise over to other directors then
we get to the big reveal you never told
me your name why do you want to know my
name cuz I want to know who I'm looking
at what did you
say ah the dog barking in the distance
perfectly timed because Casey now
suspects intruders are in the vicinity
and that's why the dog is barking
suddenly we all just become very very
paranoid over how many Wom windows and
doors are in this house now throughout
the sequence and throughout the whole
film really Wes Craven uses these Dutch
angles and he keeps everything slightly
a skew combined with a wide angle
anamorphic lens which often squeezes and
warps the edges of the frame to kind of
create this Fun House Effect which gives
us a sense that everything is off
balance like running from this killer
would be like running in a dream just
difficult and sluggish and impossible
before Casey learns that they've
captured Steve actually you can briefly
see his shadow silhouette through the
patio door glass in the shot just to the
left of her arm and what's crazy sneaks
in these little details it's all in
plain sight just to give you a sense of
paranoia and Dread as you're watching it
like wait did did I just see something
there when Casey has asked a trivia
question about Halloween you can
actually faintly hear John Carpenter
score for that movie mingling in with
the existing
music can't the killer asked Casey to
name the killer in the horror movie
Friday the 13th and she incorrectly says
Jason when it's really Jason's mother
Mrs Vorhees who does all the killing in
the original film screenwriter Kevin
Williamson has said that he used this
question at bar trivia to win himself
free drinks and anytime you see Kevin
Williamson buy him a drink because this
movie is perfectly structured from a
screenplay perspective the killer asks
what door am I at now while the question
about Mrs Vorhees wasn't really a trick
question because that is just the
factual truth of that movie this
actually is a trick question because
there are two killers both doors are
currently covered now according to
fangoria the ghost face mask was first
developed for novelty stores during the
Halloween season between 1991 and 1992
by Fun World Its design comes from
Edward monks the scream in the the film
poster of Pink Floyd's The Wall
according to this film's costume
designer it's meant to look like someone
screaming and crying at the same time
but the man of the ghost face mask in
this closeup is actually director Wes
Craven who apparently actually took a
pretty hard hit to the head with a
cordless phone while shooting Craven
will appear in another iconic costume
later in the movie but this shot of
ghost face chasing Casey down as an
homage to how Leatherface chased his
victims in the original Texas Chainsaw
Massacre Casey's muted cries for help
are very similar to those of jam Lee
curtis' screams in Halloween 2 sometimes
you're so frightened that when you
scream nothing comes out then this shot
of Casey being dragged along the ground
is an aage to a similar shot from
Dimension 13 the first movie directed by
Francis Ford Copa it was produced by
exploitation Master Roger Corman whose
filmography includes some of the
greatest movie titles of all time
including a bucket of blood and Slumber
Party Massacre 2 Corman would actually
get a cameo as a movie executive in
Scream 3 then the closeup of a hanged
Casey's face is similar to a shot in the
movie opening murder Dario Argento
susperia Casey's father tells her mother
to drive down to the McKenzie which is a
nod to align line from Halloween where
Jam Lee Curtis tells the kids to go down
the street to the macken's the Halloween
franchise repaid the favor in Halloween
H2O which includes the line drive down
to the Beckers the Beckers being Casey
Becker's family in this movie this
connection is extra strong because Kevin
Williamson was also involved in the
writing for Halloween H2O he knew what
he was doing now this movie draws a ton
of inspiration obviously from horror
movie history but also from real life
something that actually ties in with a
lot of those of us from the new Rockstar
staff Williamson was actually inspired
by the real life story of the
Gainesville Ripper a serial killer who
terrorized college students in 1990 was
in and around the campus of the
University of Florida where myself and
Brandon barck and Zach huddon all met
and actually did improv together on an
improv team and we very much knew the
history of the Gainesville Ripper now
the original title for the movie Scream
was scary movie which would later be
used for the parody series but the
change was apparently made because the
producers were listening to the Michael
Jackson song Scream and just kind of
liked the title for a horror movie and
we meet Sydney Prescott she locks her
bedroom door by barricading it with a
closet door which is a nice little setup
for how she locks out the killer later
Billy Lumis climbs into Sydney's window
similar to how Johnny Depp's Glenn
climbs into ny's window in a Nightmare
on Elm Street Billy Lumis actually gets
its name from two iconic horror movies
Dr Samuel Lumis and Halloween that's
Michael Myers psychiatrist there's also
Sam Lumis and Hitchcock Psycho Mari and
Crane's boyfriend Billy tells Sydney I
was home watching television the uh The
Exorcist was on got me thinking of you
you know all the good stuff was cut out
ah this sets up his obsession with
violence and with scary movies and the
fact that the Exorcist got him in the
mood for Shadows the character
definitely has a mental link between Sex
and Death an acoustic cover of Don't
Fear the Reaper by Gus black can be
heard in the
background in addition to being a nice
little bit of foreshadowing as to who
one of the killers ends up being Don't
Fear the Reaper fear this guy it's
actually another nod to Halloween that
movie features the blue oyer cult
version of the
song interesting to note the acoustic
version in Scream contains absolutely no
cowbell now if you have an online
business you're going to want to make
sure everything looks and works smoothly
before the holidays roll around which
means right now now is the right time to
check out Squarespace Squarespace is an
all-in-one platform that provides you
with everything you need to do whatever
you need with your website Squarespace
has templates and designs for pretty
much everything so when you're making
your very first website using
Squarespace makes it super easy to
customize your look update content and
add features to fit your unique needs
for instance Squarespace makes it easy
to sell merch you can design your
products then save time and money by
letting Squarespace handle production
inventory and shipping and if you're
selling any other kind of physical Goods
digital Goods or even a service
Squarespace makes it easy to build your
storefront and grow your business to
check it out for yourself head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com new rockstars to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or a domain really the whole point of
this sneaky makeout scene isn't just so
Billy can go from rated to nc7
everything in this worldview is horror
movie references really it's just to
distract Sydney while Stu kidnaps her
dad because noticed Mr Prescott is
wearing the same clothes when he shows
up in Stu's house later Woodsboro high
school was actually the somoma county
community center as most of this movie
was shot near and around Hillsburg
California wine country where a lot of
homes really are spread out from each
other in the middle of nowhere
originally they were going to shoot the
high school at Santa Rosa high school
but the high school backed out of a
verbal agreement at the last minute
according to the movie's executive
producer Maran Melana which is why the
end credits include quote no thanks
whatsoever to the Santa Rosa city school
district governing board and even in
this wide shot immediately we see Gail
weathers Courtney Cox standing out with
her neon green suit this movie uses a
brighter shade of green as a way to
highlight Accenture characters who
actually end up not being The Killers
like with the case of ry's shoes in the
principal's office we meet principal
Arthur hry his first name Arthur being a
reference to Arthur Fonzerelli aka the
fwn from Happy Days get some great Happy
Days shout outs later now the names
behind Sheriff Burke here are actually
the names of art Department crew members
on this movie like Art Williams was a
carpenter keny montante was a local lead
person Deborah ichard was a set
decorator Richard Lambert was the lead
person Josh Elliott is Onset dresser
Michelle pul was a set decorator
Charlene bar was the art Department
production assistant they helped make
all the Blood and Guts and breakway
glass happen in this movie which is why
I listed all their names because so much
of what's great about scream is this
crew and the cop here is actually played
by Joseph whip who also plays a cop in
Nightmare on Elm Street Craven has even
said that the characters could be one of
the same which would suggest an insane
shared Universe actually in a cut scene
Sydney types her address as 34 Elm
Street there's some really interesting
foreshadowing Clues here in the scene by
the fountain like Stu doesn't exactly
hide to anything by explaining with
creepy detail how to gut someone and how
it would take a man's strength all the
characters are seated in a way that
their shoes are visible everyone wears
lightly colored shoes like Randy wears
bright green ones but Stu and Billy both
wear heavy black boots the shoes the
killer wears Stu says I didn't kill
anybody nobody said you did thanks buddy
yeah this is a hint between the killers
that it wasn't Stu who actually fatally
stabbed Casey it was Billy Stu was just
the one who strung her up they wonder if
the killer could be a woman like in
basic instin in that's a 1992 erotic
Thriller starring Sharon Stone where her
character kills victims with an ice pick
Stone actually gets a total of three
shout outs in this movie and it kind of
feels like the movie's picking on her
quite a bit but actually her first major
film role was back in Wes Craven's
deadly blessing which is an absolutely
insane 1981 Thriller about a community
of murderous Amish people while the
villain of scream does not turn out to
be a woman in this movie there will be
female ghost faces later on in the
series Sydney cautiously checks her
mailbox still a little nervous after
Randy in the previous scene said did you
really put her liver in the mailbox cuz
I heard that they found her liver in the
mailbox next to her spleen and her
pancreas ry's Voice work being on her
mind is why she assumes it's Randy
calling when the killer calls are you
alone in the house this Line's a
reference to the 1978 made for TV movie
are you in the house alone about a
teenager who's terrorized with
threatening phone calls Sydney actually
repeats this line in the Final Act of
the film when she turns the tables on
Billy and stew are you alone in the
house while it's Billy on the phone it's
Stu who savagely tries to kill Sydney in
the house it's fun to just imagine
Matthew Lillard goofy taking all these
hits actually listen closely as he
chases her up the
stairs another clue that this is stew as
he will say the same exact thing to
Tatum by the lockers the next day easy
now Sydney actually uses a de typer
program to dial 911 which was a TTY
service that Sydney must have looked up
as a way to message people she's pretty
clever now the shot of Billy's face here
is a big wow this guy has got to be the
killer kind of framing according to
Kevin Williamson the idea here for me is
that point the finger at him so
blatantly that the audience immediately
knows no he's not the killer Tatum
arrives driving an old red BW Beetle
which is a reference to Stephen King's
The Shining Stephen King's The Shining
not Stanley Kubrick's The Shining
because Jack torren drove a red beetle
in the novel kubri referenced it in the
film adaptation where a crush red beetle
was involved in a snowy accident with a
semi-truck people think that this might
have been shot at Stephen King by
Stanley Kubrick since King wrote a first
tra at screenplay and Kubrick
essentially rejected it because he
thought it was too literal of an
adaptation of the novel both Stephen
King's book The Shining and Stanley
cop's film The Shining both amazing
works of horror fiction but just very
different things now the costume
packaging of the ghost face costume is
actually labeled father death Craven
said that this was an intentional
misdirection to make the audience think
the killer was Sid's father but
Williamson never knew this or meant that
to be the meaning in the screenplay so
Sydney socks Gail Weathers in the jaw
and she stays the night with Tatum who
has on her wall a photo of Grant goodie
this is from the 80s sitcom 8 is enough
an extended version of the grocery store
scene would have actually included Tatum
telling Sydney that he was her sexual
Awakening and when she was having sex
with Stu she thinks of this actor
actually speaking of Stu it's obviously
Stu is the killer who calls Sydney while
Billy's in jail which is why he's less
gameplaying and just more direct and
thenis some guy doesn't stand a chance
with you now it could be argued that
Billy and Stu intentionally got Billy
caught so that they could exonerate him
with Stu's call and the clear cell
record and makes Sid even more paranoid
for accusing the wrong man for her
mother's murder Le of shriber appears as
cotton weary The Man Billy and Stu
framed for Sydney's mother's murder
cotton actually returns in the sequel
and in the opening sequence of Scream 3
another reporter gets in Sid's face how
does it feel to be almost brutally
butchered this is a cameo by horror
Legend Linda Blair from The Exorcist her
crucifix earrings suggested that she's
still looking to repel demons Blair
actually worked with Wes Craven in the
made for TV movie Stranger in her house
the novel that movie is based on
features the scene where a pet dog is
killed Craven actually changed it to a
horse for his movie because he knew
Linda Blair loved horses and it would
get a better performance out of her he
actually ended up doing something
similar for scream where he had dog
lover Drew Barrymore recall an upsetting
dog based news story when she needed to
cry on command at the locker Stu checks
out his reflection in Tatum's mirror
trying to see if his scuffle was sit at
her house left any bruises on his head
Stu also mentions Candyman in reference
to the 1992 horror film another great
classic principal H gets extra vicious
with the two pranksters and the idea
that there's two of them definitely sets
us up to consider the possibility that
it might be two killers working in
tandem the kids walk home from school
looks very much like the Pasadena
sidewalks that served as hat and field
in Halloween but perhaps the most
hilariously obvious reference in this
movie is this janitor named Fred dressed
as the OG Freddy Krueger costume and yes
it's a cameo by Wes Craven not only
referencing A Nightmare on Elm Street
but the work of Hitchcock as well
because Hitchcock always had fun cameos
in his own movies we get a few more
Happy Days F references the F's black
leather jacket from Happy Days hangs in
hre's closet he's also seen checking out
his hair in the mirror a patented FS
move now principal hry is only killed
here by Ghostface because producer Bob
Weinstein felt the film had gone on too
long I guess roughly 30 pages without a
death and somebody's got to Die the
closeup on principal hre's eye during
his death is a omage to the zoom out on
Mary in Crane's eye as she's stabbed to
death in the bathroom by Norman Bates
and psycho now Tatum says that she can't
help but believe the rumors about Sid's
mom sleeping around I mean you can only
hear that Richard Gear drible story so
many times before you have to start
believing it so this is an not to the
debunked rumor that Richard Gear checked
into a hospital to have a Geral removed
from his rectum it's one of the craziest
Hollywood myths that I as a kid after
watching this movie believ really the
story came from a prankster who after
Pretty Woman came out flooded fa
machines in Hollywood with a phony press
release from the associ assciation for
Prevention of Cruelty to animals with
this bogus claim and in retrospect it's
just an interesting line from Rose mwan
light of this film's executive producer
Harvey Weinstein whose Hollywood rumors
about him end up being 100% true
unfortunately also he's totally the kind
of guy who would put out misinformation
by flooding Hollywood facts machines to
discredit people Tatum says you're
starting to sound like some West
Carpenter flick or something yes she's
deliberately mixing up the names of West
Craven and Halloween director John
Carpenter and while she's saying that
she's wearing a number 10 crop Jersey
similar to the one Johnny Depp wears in
Elm Street during his death scene fact
that she's wearing this could be
foreshadowing her own eventual Grizzly
death the grizzli and craziest of this
movie James Wales Frankenstein plays on
the TV in the video store this was
released in 1931 it's the oldest movie
to get a direct reference in Scream a
teen asks Randy at the video store what
that movie with the werewolf and et's
Mom is Drew Barrymore was an ET and
Randy answers the howling which starred
D Wallace and Wallace was in a bunch of
horror movies like West Cravens The
Hills Have Eyes Cujo and others and I
just love that she calls D Wallace et's
mom Randy say says the whole thing is
prom Knight Revisited a nod to the 1980
horror movie prom KN night which starred
Jam Lee Curtis prom Knight another movie
that featured the threatening phone call
Trope you can also see a poster for the
jam Lee Curtis movie mother's boys in
the video store but knowing Billy and
Stu are The Killers makes their gain up
on Randy pretty scary as he rightfully
sees through stew trying to pin it on
Sid's dad and thinks it's Billy who says
that Randy is an equally possible
suspect which Randy acknowledges even
though he has no motive it's the
Millennium motives are incidental now
it's an odd line for anyone born late
enough to not remember 9/11 but for '90s
kids Society was freaked the out about
Y2K and Randy attributing random
psychopathy does actually apply to the
co- killer behind him because Billy has
motive for his killings but Stu just
really just does it for the fun or as he
says later peer pressure I'm far too
sensitive so as the town of Woodsboro
prepares for curfew the song red R Hand
by Nick Cave and the Bad Seeds plays
this song actually comes back in many
Scream movies except 2011 Scream 4 it's
f that the name of Nick Cav's band is
the Bad Seeds because a movie with a
title of the Bad Seeds will be popping
up later Sydney says that the deserted
streets in Westboro remind her of the
town that dreaded Sundown that was a
1976 movie that is also inspired by real
life events the Tex Arcana Moonlight
murders now it's easy to forget how
silly this movie gets by making you
think everyone could be a suspect like
when the sheriff tells Dewey that they
trace the calls to Sid's father Neil he
looks real jumpy and starts smoking
again and then West Craven cuts to an
ominous closeup of his dark
boots So Randy has a hul videos in the
video store we got Hellraiser the Evil
Dead the fog Terror train prom Knight
and of course Halloween which we see the
party watching later there's a VHS copy
of 1994's Clerks on top of the VCR next
to where Gail weathers places a
camcorder to spy on the teens Jay and
Silent Bob later have a quick Cameo and
Scream 3 where they ask gaale if she's
Connie Chong so Stu sends Tatum into the
garage for more beer and this proves
that he later knows that she was in
there and later when he goes for a beer
this is before he jokes I'll be right
back he would have had to go to the
garage 41 and we never see him coming
back freaking out over Tatum's corpse
proving that it must have been him who
killed her Tatum says I Spit on Your
Garage a reference to the exploitation
classic I Spit on Your Grave now in this
scene this is apparently the only time
in the whole movie that anyone refers to
the killer as Ghostface because Tatum
playfully calls him Mr ghost face
because she thinks it's Randy in costume
just messing around so Tatum's death in
the garage door is just Bonkers Craven
and Williamson said that their original
plan was for Tatum to get crushed under
the door but when they saw the door had
a pet door they decided to rework and to
keep Rose Macwan in place they nailed
her top to the garage door this
this actress had to endure Randy calls
Billy Leatherface a reference to the
villain in the Texas Chainsaw Massacre
which also had a real life inspiration
from The Edge murders Sydney worries
that she's a bad seed and the Bad Seed
is a 1956 movie about a murderous child
who kills with her tap shoes Craven is
actually called The Bad Seed one of his
favorite horror movies of all time Billy
also Nam drops the Silence of the Lambs
a movie which we'll learn later was an
inspiration for his Killing Spree
actually the poster for the Silence of
the Lambs and the poster for screen
share many visual similarities So Randy
shares with the audience the rules to
survive a horror movie number one you
can never have sex number two you can
never drink or do drugs and number three
never say I'll be right back the rules
are really just like my favorite thing
about the Scream movie franchise and new
ones actually get added for every sequel
but in this movie the point of the rules
is to show how they are subverted the
three survivors of this movie all break
the rules of the movie Sydney has sex
Randy gets drunk and Gail totally says
at one point I'll be right back actually
in Friday the 13th Part Two Jenny and
Paul have sex Lorie stroe drinks and
smokes pot but the characters in Scream
are really the first ones who are
self-aware of their own genre which both
creatively inspires The Killers of these
movies while also giving the victims A
playbook to try to survive similarly
While most zombie stories take place in
Worlds that have never had zombie movies
to learn from 2009 Zombie Land is
influenced by in Universe zombie fiction
and is also a movie governed by rules so
after doing the deed Sydney asks Billy
who he called for his one phone call and
he says his dad now Sydney's not wrong
to suspect him but it was actually Stu
who called her while Billy was in prison
so Stu fix stabs Billy and initially
there is no blood on the knife but that
might just be a production thing because
after cutting to Sydney and back to him
for the wipe there is some fake blood on
it now Sydney locks the door to get away
from the killer but then the Ghost Face
Killer appears around the other Corner
another stew clue because only someone
who lived in this house would know so
quickly how to take all these shortcuts
while Sydney is running through Stew's
attic we see these creepy doll strung up
like Casey was in the cold open this not
only shows us that Stu has been
practicing his murder techniques but
it's reference to the Dario aril classic
deep red that features a killer who is
obsessed with dolls and toys in one
scene a doll hangs from a noose not
unlike the ones we see in this room
before he's attacked Randy says look
behind you Jamie referencing Jamie Lee
Curtis in the movie but he's played by
actor Jamie Kennedy so he may as well be
talking to himself Jamie Kennedy is
literally reflected in the glass of the
TV screen right over Jam Lee Curtis in
that shot it creates this great
multi-layered metag gag in which Sid and
the cameraman Kenny scream at the TV
behind you Ken Kenny and when we watch
this we realize we're doing the same
thing look behind you Jamie Kenny
remembers the 30-second delay and gets
killed now Kenny is played by W Earl
Brown who would go on to appear in
Deadwood the Mandalorian and played Bill
in The Last of Us game Sydney's blood
drenched hitchhiking is a reference to
Carrie might also remind viewers of
Sally's Escape From The Texas Chainsaw
Massacre but Carrie gets name dropped a
few minutes later when Billy says that
he used corn syrup for his fake blood
like they did for Pig's blood and Carrie
so Dewey gets stabbed and Sydney hides
inside her car and gets away grabs dwi's
gun and then Randy and Stu show up at
the same time I found T she's dead I
think Ste my now remember Tatum is Stu's
girlfriend he should be more concerned
with where she is or whether she's okay
the fact that only Randy cares about
Tatum should tell Sid that Stu is a
killer but they're both frantically
yelling so she can't trust either of
them Billy reveals himself as Randy
really set him up perfectly to quote
psycho here he's gone
mad we all go a little mad sometimes now
it's interesting that he attributes a
quote to Anthony Perkins from psycho not
Norman Bates the actor not the character
just another sign that Billy really has
trouble distinguishing movies from
reality meanwhile Matthew Lillard I got
to say just such a goofball when he
trades Billy the knife for the gun like
M he's barely even in the frame here but
every move this actor makes is unhinged
like earlier when school lets out you
can see him in the background leaping
into frame cutting people off and then
pulling up a flower from the garden now
the pose that the two killers make here
is kind of a two-headed Beast an homage
to the thing with two heads and when
pressed for a motive Billy says that
it's scarier when the villain doesn't
have a motive he mentions Hannibal
Lecter and Norman Bates but the Bates
parallel here doesn't really fit the
theory because both Bates and Billy are
dealing with issues around their mothers
and their sexuality so there is kind of
a motive there but by saying that it's
scary when they don't have a motive I
think Billy is on to something viewers
might be reminded of the motive light
killers from the modern slasher classic
the strangers and when asked why they
were doing this one simply replies
because you were home but as Stu and
Billy explain their plan to blame it all
on Sid's father Sid says you seen one
too many movies no Sid don't you blame
the movies movies don't creat psychos
movies make psychos or creative again we
see the flaw in Billy's Thinking by
copying what he sees in movies Billy
isn't being creative he's being by
definition derivative one controversial
take is that the real life murderers
these movies were based on were the true
creatives but even then I don't think we
should call those people creative
because by destroying lives you're not
creating anything Gail's return gives
Sid an opening to hide and turn the
tables on the boys Sid pops out of the
closet to surprise the killer just like
Jamie Lee Curtis does in Halloween and
that scene plays on the TV in the Next
Room she uses a green umbrella the hero
color contrasting the red blood Sydney
tells stew in your drink and then
crushes SL zaps him with the TV Killers
obsessed with horror movies literally
get killed with one Nightmare on Elm
Street 3 also features death by
television Gail finally learns to take
the safety off and shoots Billy even
though Randy warns that there's always
one final scare and the jump scare works
not in my movie like Ripley at the end
of alien Sydney signals that she's aware
that she's part of a Hollywood Story and
ends it on her own terms Gail reports
from the crime scene ring to an end the
harrowing mystery of the mass killings
that has terrified this peaceful
community like the plot of some scary
movie yes a little not too scary movie
Kevin Williamson's original title for
this film and then as the film Fades to
Black yeah West gven proves Randy right
with one final scare just a few frames
from our very first close-up of ghost
face in the opening sequence when it was
Wes Craven himself under the mask what
is your favorite moment from West Craven
scream we loved revisiting this classic
in our favorite time of year and
hopefully we pointed out something new
new rock stars loves to break down the
details you miss in everything you love
and please check out our ranking of jump
scares and nonh horror films huge thanks
to Jordan Morris and Eric auu for
helping write this analysis please
subscribe to the new rockstars Network
and you can follow me on all socials at
eaos thanks for watching
[Music]
bye